[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 21 juin voici le programme
de ce soir en début d'émission nous
ferons le point sur les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines au
programme l'arrivée de trottinette
électrique dans deux communes Yvelines
le l'Atmos qui obtient un label ou
encore le château de Versailles qui fête
ses 400 ans et puis le mercredi comme
d'habitude nous parlerons également
d'éducation en juin les étudiants
accélèrent leurs recherches pour trouver
une alternance à la rentrée pour les
aider certaines écoles renforcent leur
offre avec les entreprises du territoire
on en parle avec notre journaliste
Régine ralech et bien sûr ce soir c'est
la fête de la musique partout en France
et les Yvelines ne dérochent pas
exactement des véhicules exposés
également derrière les Davidson des
véhicules américains etc et des
spectacles aussi pour enfants et tout
en face de vous Philippe vollac bonsoir
alors vous êtes le responsable des
sponsors pour l'entreprise orange en
Île-de-France et vous venez nous parler
de Laurent l'orange Rugby Challenge
pareil en quelques mots c'est quoi le
rôle du challenge
c'est un challenge comme on dit c'est
sur ça se fait au niveau national il y a
des phases départementales il y a une
phase régionale et une fan nationale qui
s'est déroulée au son d'un solde de
rugby de Linda Marcoussis le weekend
dernier où il y avait un représentant
une équipe représentante l'Île-de-France
et ça réunit 1100 clubs et plus de 8000
enfants de 14 à 15 ans on en parlera
également
plus fin d'émission on sera accompagné
de deux jeunes participants du Rugby
Club de Montesson et avec nous également
ce soir une journaliste de la rédaction
de TV 78 régénéralege bonsoir bonsoir
alors avec vous on parlera d'éducation
avec votre chronique éditoque mais vous
allez également nous présenter les
informations à retenir dans les Yvelines
ce sera juste après les prévisions météo
de demain
[Musique]
demain matin les Yvelines seront sous la
pluie selon Météo France au niveau des
températures ça se rafraîchit compter 16
degrés à Rambouillet 17 degrés à ou dans
et Versailles et 18 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi le
ciel s'éclaircit du côté de Houdain et
Mantes-la-Jolie mais dans le secteur de
Versailles et Rambouillet il y aura
encore quelques averses côté température
il fera 19 degrés à Rambouillet et
Versailles 20 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
et 21 degrés à Houdan et demain nous
fêterons la Saint Alban le pont
maintenant sur les informations du jour
à retenir dans les Yvelines
et on commence ces informations régimes
avec du nouveau pour le l'Atmos et oui
hier Sylvie retaillou la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche a annoncé que le projet France
2030 de l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines a été retenu
le but coordonner l'ensemble des
établissements franciliens concernés par
le spatial sur l'apprentissage en écoute
Philippe cude vice-président rechercher
innovation à l'université vers 16
Saint-Quentin cette décision c'est d'une
part avoir des moyens puisque c'est un
projet à 21 millions d'euros donc avec
les plus grandes universités nous on va
pouvoir travailler main dans la main
pour identifier mettre en place de
nouvelles formations puisque le secteur
bouge on a besoin de s'adapter nous
aussi en tant que académique
des militants de la droite ce sont
donnés rendez-vous hier à la mairie
d'Élancourt et oui une réunion c'est une
réunion publique c'est tenue pour
débattre et parler de sujets d'actualité
au niveau régional et nationale le but
était de redynamiser la vie militante
reconstruire la famille politique de la
droite
Othman Nasro vice-président de la Région
Île-de-France était présent on l'écoute
voyez les gens qui sont là ils auraient
pu prendre du temps pour rester en
famille pour faire autre chose de leur
temps il y a même un jeune ce soir qui
fêtait son anniversaire et qui était
malgré tout là des gens qui croient à la
droite et bien il y en a encore et il y
en a besoin et c'est ça mon motif
d'espoir parce que moi j'ai la
conviction que le pays ne se relèvera
que si la droite est au rendez-vous
parce que je ne veux pas d'un duel en
2027 entre l'extrême droite et l'extrême
gauche et ben ça commence maintenant ça
commence par ce travail et il faut que
tout le monde s'y mette
et la caravane de la compagnie des
aidants était de passage aujourd'hui
attrape et c'est d'ailleurs la sixième
année consécutive que la caravane de la
compagnie des aidants sillonne les
routes de France le but est d'offrir un
temps d'écoute de soutien et de conseils
aux aidants qui prennent soin au
quotidien d'un proche fragilisé par la
maladie par le handicap par la
vieillesse ou encore par des accidents
de la vie et dans son tour de France la
caravane s'est arrêtée aujourd'hui à
Trappes on écoute Marie de Verbier chef
de projet à la compagnie des aidants au
micro de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude on
se rend compte que les aidants ils n'ont
pas accès à l'information ils ne savent
pas que des choses existent des
structures des que les départements
mettent en place aussi également des
choses pour les aidants et en fait il
nous a paru important de créer cet
événement pour justement l'axe que
l'accès information et l'accès aux
droits soient fait pour les aidants et
on poursuit avec l'Histoire de France
Régine l'un des sites les plus
emblématiques de notre pays faites
aujourd'hui
400 ans et c'est en septembre 1623 que
Louis XII décide de l'aménagement d'un
pavillon de chasse sur un domaine de 800
hectares alors ce lieu c'est bien
entendu le château de Versailles un
universel important pour sa présidence
Catherine pegard qui désire montrer que
ce monument est plus vivant que jamais
alors tout au long tout au long de cette
année spéciale diverses expositions et
événements seront organisés le prochain
rendez-vous est d'ailleurs le 27 juin
prochain les appartements privés
restaurés de Marie-Antoinette
s'ouvriront au public alors on en a
parlé en début d'émission aujourd'hui
c'est aussi la fête de la musique et ce
n'est pas un hasard si la région
Île-de-France a choisi cette journée
pour lancer un appel à candidature
visant à aider les artistes musicaux et
oui Mathilde il s'agit de la seconde
édition du dispositif l'île des chances
pour soutenir la création musicale
enregistrement d'un album réalisation
d'un clip ou aide à la création scénique
tout est pensé pour l'émergence des
créateurs de musique le principe chaque
artiste sélection par la région aura une
page internet pour lancer une collecte
de fonds sur la plateforme Kiss Kiss
bankbank.com et de son côté
l'Île-de-France doublera le montant
obtenu de cette levée de fond dans la
limite de 5000 euros alors si vous aussi
vous êtes tenté vous avez jusqu'au 15
septembre 2023 pour postuler sur le site
de la Région Île-de-France et on termine
ces informations du jour Régine avec du
football et oui c'est d'ailleurs une
bonne nouvelle pour le FC Versailles qui
a réussi son passage devant la DNCG donc
le gendarme financier du football
français confirme le maintien du FCV
dans le championnat de National la masse
salariale sera en revanche encadrée afin
de s'assurer de la pérennité du club qui
a terminé 5e du dernier exercice alors
en difficulté financière en cette fin de
saison Versailles a été repris début
juin par le petit-fils du fondateur du
groupe Auchan Alexandre Mulliez et bien
merci beaucoup au régime ralege pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
information ou une image qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 78
dans l'actualité également la fête de la
musique bien évidemment c'est ce soir et
les Yvelines sont au rendez-vous on
retrouve tout de suite sur place notre
journaliste Mickael el Mido qui est à
l'hôtel de ville de Plaisir Michael quel
est le programme de ce soir à plaisir
le grand premières ici à côté de l'hôtel
de ville dans le désir il est une
nouvelle scène jusqu'à été installé
juste derrière nous et les deux plus
beaux se succès
on vous entend pas très bien il doit y
avoir un petit problème technique au
niveau du son je propose d'aller voir
tout de suite Grégory canalet qui se
trouve lui à la batterie de Guyancourt
et ensuite on essaie de vous reprendre
Grégory quel est le programme à la
batterie de Guyancourt
bonsoir Mathilde Guyancourt les concerts
ont commencé à 18h vous voyez derrière
moi il y a les seins de la plaine de
nauf notamment qui sont sur une ambiance
plutôt pop rock et dans la ville de
Guyancourt c'est même sept lieues ce
soir qui vont proposer des concerts à
l'occasion de la Fête de la Musique
François Morton bonsoir bonsoir Le Maire
de Guyancourt justement pourquoi
proposer un gros programme pour cette
fête de la musique quels sont les
objectifs de la soirée écoutez la fête
de la musique a Guyancourt c'est
historique ça fait déjà de nombreuses
années qu'on a fait et c'est vrai qu'il
y a 2 ans on s'est dit qu'on souhaitait
revenir à l'esprit originel de la fête
de la musique le 21 juin dans les
quartiers dans la rue chez les
commerçants dans les maisons de quartier
dans les centres sociaux et ça a été le
cas l'année dernière et cette année
c'est encore le cas et ça va nous
permettre à la fois de nous balader dans
la ville d'aller voir tous les styles de
musique possible et probablement de nous
retrouver tous ici après le programme
pour vous ce soir vous allez naviguer
entre les différents concerts dans la
ville absolument je vais partir tout de
suite après cette petite interview
il y a aussi avec nous Stéphane ridhark
chargé de la programmation culturelle
pour la batterie alors je le disais les
concerts ont déjà démarré même depuis
17h30 elle concerne derrière nous il
vient de démarrer quel est le programme
de la soirée sur la ville de Guyancourt
et à la batterie alors pour la batterie
précisément on investit vraiment tout le
pôle musique c'est à dire que de l'autre
côté à l'école de musique qui a nos
enseignants qui sont déjà en train de
travailler de présenter leur programme
et avec avec leurs élèves sur la scène
du parking en effet il va y avoir un
certain de choses dans la salle même de
la batterie que certains d'entre nous
connaissent bien qui ont joué aux 450
600 là on est en petite jauge à 450 il y
a des concerts aussi jusqu'à minuit et
puis on investit aussi
l'amphithéâtre qui a entre le entre
l'auditorium et les salles de cours il
va y avoir un groupe que vous allez
avoir l'occasion de d'interviewer très
prochainement je crois un groupe de pop
rock l'idée c'est de valoriser la
pratique amateur aussi de la musique
complètement son mes collègues des
studios Christophe et Gilles que je
remercie avec
donc Amélie Barbara enfin toute l'équipe
du service événementiel aussi que
Monsieur le Maire a créé il y a très peu
de temps voilà on a vraiment renforcé
cette idée que la musique doit être
présente partout à Guyancourt donc voilà
je crois que ce sera un bon rendez-vous
il pleut pas en plus on a de la chance
donc on va pouvoir se promener pour les
gens qui aiment la musique tahitienne il
y a une initiation à la danse haïtienne
de Jason de nos collègues dans une des
maisons de quartier il y a le club de
you fulélé de de Guyancourt qui est
monté depuis deux ans par Morgan qui
fera une intervention sur le parvis de
l'Hôtel de Ville donc voilà un programme
assez foisonnant donc on a vite vraiment
l'aiguille en Tourtois à sortir de chez
eux et à venir s'amuser avec nous on a
pour tous les goûts ce soir vous
l'entendez peut-être derrière moi un
petit sol men de main de Ben l'Oncle
Soul qui a été proposé on a entendu
aussi Shadow le le la musique du film de
star is born qui a été proposé tout à
l'heure on aura l'occasion tout à
l'heure d'aller interviewer l'un des
artistes qui est programmé ce soir et on
se retrouve tout à l'heure bien sûr pour
vous faire vivre cette fête de la
musique ici à Guyancourt merci beaucoup
Grégory canalet on vous retrouve
effectivement
tout à l'heure on passe à Mickaël midoro
Michael je crois que le son est revenu
alors quel est le programme à plaisir
c'est une grande première à ici à côté
de l'hôtel de ville de plaisir et ils
veulent faire les choses en grand ici à
plaisir alors le programme va être très
complet ce soir il y aura un petit peu
de tout au niveau de la musique alors on
a vu il y a quelques instants les
passages de John strings qui est un
groupe de pop rock actuellement il y a
jong-steps qui est juste derrière moi et
il y aura également Mondays Watchers
dans quelques instants il y aura
également des ateliers de jazz du
conservatoire ce sont principalement des
groupes locaux qui se produisent ce soir
il y a The Voice radio garage Revenge of
The Geeks et la soirée se terminera aux
alentours de 23h30 minuit avec des DJ
qui vont enflammer ici cet endroit à
plaisir et il y a eu quelques il y a eu
quelques instants de personnalités des
talents de plaisir qui se sont produits
sur scène je vais leur demander de venir
alors il y a rose et Jade qui sont à mes
côtés alors rose comment ça c'est passé
il y a quelques instants sur la scène de
plaisir pas trop impressionnant non ça
peut aller j'étais assez un peu un
manque d'alèse sur les mouvements pour
inviter un peu le public à regarder mais
franchement ça s'est bien passé et tu as
gagné du coup le concours talent de
plaisir c'est bien ça oui c'est ça qui
se déroulait le 27 mai dernier donc j'ai
gagné le premier prix de ce comporte et
il y a également eu la quatrième de ce
concours jade alors jade comment ça
s'est passé sur scène il y a quelques
instants c'est toujours un peu stressant
mais c'était cool cette scène justement
les comment quand on voit le le monde
devant soi
[Musique]
on a de plus en plus donc c'est pour ça
va
et l'interaction avec le public c'était
comment
pas vraiment assez proche on pouvait
voir leur réaction directement sur leur
visage alors les groupes vont se
succéder dans quelques instants est-ce
que vous allez rester vous pour toute
cette soirée de la Fête de la Musique
bah il me semble que j'ai des amis qui
jouent donc je vais aller voir un petit
peu ce qu'ils vont faire ce soir super
merci beaucoup merci à toutes les deux
je vous laisse profiter du spectacle moi
aussi je vais continuer à en profiter un
peu et on se retrouve je crois un peu
plus tard Merci à VOUS Mickaël midoron
on se retrouve effectivement un petit
peu plus tard pour suivre l'ambiance à
plaisir de la fête de la musique et
également merci à Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude et Julien Leroy qui sont au
moyen technique allez je vous propose de
faire un saut au Bourget vous l'aurez
compris la 54e édition du Salon
International de l'Aéronautique et de
l'Espace se déroule au Bourget et ce
jusqu'à dimanche prochain tous les
acteurs mondiaux de l'aéronautique et du
spatial sont réunis pendant une semaine
et les Yvelines sont encore une nouvelle
fois bien représentées avec Airbus
Thalès safran ou encore Atos cette année
d'ailleurs l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à son propre
stand et parmi les entreprises
implantées à Sky le groupe espagnol CT
nous retrouvons sur place notre
journaliste Nicolas dandry le groupe CT
est implanté sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines plus
précisément à Guyancourt c'est un groupe
espagnol et je suis avec le CO de ce
groupe CT David Prieto bonsoir alors
déjà un mot sur CT et c'était une
générique en pourquoi c'est important
d'être présent sur le salon du Bourget
presque à 10000 collaborateurs en Europe
et ce groupe des capital espagnol mais
avec une très faux stratégie dans la
France donc nous sommes présentés à
sandre les rouget parce qu'ils nous
sommes en dulecance et soustratrons des
premières Nivelles de argus donc c'est
très beau temps pour nous était là et
ils ne sont très content d'être là
spécialement et avec les quatre ongles
ont passé entre les covid et maintenant
alors Airbus vous venez de le mentionner
l'un de vos principaux votre client
Airbus qui est présent sur le territoire
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines Airbus
défunt space à Élancourt pourquoi
c'était important de venir sur le
territoire de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
c'est récent c'est 2019 que vous êtes
venus sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous sommes
vraiment contents avec cette
incorporation là c'était c'est en
incorporant une activité de les routes
Bertrand vous verrons d'une quelques
motifs ça nous donne de savoir-faire de
la partie du système qui est vraiment
avancé dans la partie de nous et ça ne
possédions très bien dans la partie
espace avec des clients comme Meknès
avec
vous ceci alors
c'est implanté à Guyancourt combien de
personnes travaillent sur ce site et
c'est quoi comme métier qu'on retrouve
sur ce site donc c'est plus ou moins 50
personnes et on est en train de grandir
encore donc et c'est principalement des
activités des calculs multifices qui des
systèmes donc l'application industrielle
puis ce moment dans la partie défense la
partie arrow aussi il est parti se passe
dans une très content parce que c'est
vraiment des activités des très hautes
alors ajouter techno et on a beaucoup de
docteur à reconnaissance de traiteront
avec ces incorporation on était présent
en Guyancourt et puis alors ce que vous
venez de dire ça
ça c'est un projet que c'est vraiment
intéressant parce que c'est c'est sa
combine du trou que ça combine l'espace
ça combine aussi la partie soustabilité
donc ça c'est les projets Insider les
produits said c'est un projet pour aider
à
diminuer les derberies spatial donc on a
beaucoup de satellite que sont autour de
l'allemand et
de cette sommeil d'Évian et il se casse
ils vendent des débris on a un usées
pour être
pour permis que on est plus safe en le
Déménage des nouveaux satellite il y a
les menton de dire à réduire la
contamination et spatiale voilà l'idée
c'est vraiment de capter c'est ça avec
l'aide de la technologie Dr captif c'est
de capter tous les débris pour éviter de
polluer disons
éviter des problèmes tu sais de de
collection de débris avec du nouveau
satellite c'est ça c'est très important
spécialement avec les nouveaux satellite
les mini les constellations de satellite
ensemble et on sait compter ils sont
plus petits dans les projets de vie
c'est plus gros que avant un dernier mot
maintenant sur toute cette activité
forcément il y a besoin de main d'oeuvre
il y a besoin de nouveaux collaborateurs
et vous êtes en train d'embaucher
actuellement sur le site de Guyancourt
et nous sommes en train de embaucher des
gens pour continuer sa télécimulation et
produire grandir la France et bien sûr
pour continuer à notre pression
stratégie un gagnant-go merci David
Pretto merci pour votre effort aussi
parce que je rappelle vous êtes espagnol
vous êtes le CEO du groupe CT qui est
basé donc à Madrid mais qui est aussi
implanté sur le territoire
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines merci pour les
forces d'avoir parlé en français
allez comme souvent le mercredi on parle
d'éducation dans votre émission le 7 8
avec votre chronique et du Talk original
et ce soir on va parler apprentissage et
oui tout à fait Mathilde est d'ailleurs
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure à
l'approche de l'été c'est un peu la
dernière ligne droite pour les étudiants
de trouver leur alternance mais aussi
pour les entreprises de trouver leur
talent alors justement pour en parler
avec nous Nathalie balutaud bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes directrice
campus Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines chez
edu-service donc et du service c'est un
groupe spécialisé dans l'enseignement
supérieur privé qui rassemble 30 écoles
en France et forme notamment au métier
du management du commerce du digital ou
encore du sport alors ce groupe il est
aussi très axé sur l'apprentissage ma
première question finalement c'est quel
est l'avantage pour une école de faire
partie du groupe et du service déjà ils
sont nombreux quelques quelques uns
quelques-uns des avantages tout d'abord
nous toutes nos formations sont
sanctionnées soit par des comme d'état
ou des titres certifiés par l'État très
important on a un rayonnement national
avec vous l'avez dit plus de 30 campus
et sur chaque campus plusieurs plusieurs
écoles ce qui permet aux étudiants des
passerelles à la fois sur les écoles et
sur les formations et surtout
un investissement très important sur la
pédagogie de la part du groupe et sur
l'accompagnement de nos apprentis parce
que à la fois il faut qu'il soit
performant en entreprise mais il faut
qu'ils aient les codes et la réussite
d'une formation en apprentissage c'est
l'accompagnement et justement en 2022
c'est une année record avec la barre des
837 000 nouveaux contrats
d'apprentissage qui a été franchi dans
les secteurs publics et privés est-ce
que c'est un engouement que vous
constatez aussi chez du service ah oui
oui c'est un engouement important il
faut dire déjà que alors pour vous
donner un petit repère en 2020 il y
avait un peu plus de 500 000 apprentis
contrats d'apprentissage
signé et l'objectif du gouvernement
c'est de former au moins un million
d'apprentis par an à partir de 2027 nous
on le on le on le ressent on le ressent
il faut dire que l'apprentissage apporte
énormément davantage à la fois que ce
soit pour les jeunes ou pour
l'entreprise et pour moi c'est le
meilleur tremplin pour pour l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes
justement quelles sont ses avantages de
quoi ça sert finalement l'apprentissage
et l'alternance alors parmi parmi ces
avantages on a tout d'abord une
expérience professionnelle pour le jeûne
donc la pratique la pratique en
entreprise qui est très importante qui
leur permet de développer leur
compétences et d'être plus vite
opérationnel lorsqu'ils vont chercher un
emploi ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième c'est que la formation en
apprentissage c'est une formation
gratuite et rémunérée donc non
négligeable
on a aussi la possibilité
de poursuivre tout son cursus en
apprentissage
ça c'est c'est important c'est à dire
qu'on peut commencer tout de suite après
le bac en ce qui nous concerne pour
l'enseignement supérieur et aller
jusqu'au bac + 5 ce qui est notre cas
sur nos différentes nos différents
enseignes et puis
le jeune qui fait sa formation en
apprentissage dans une entreprise
très souvent et formé aux méthodes de
l'entreprise et à une proposition de
contrat à l'issue de son de son
apprentissage et justement quelles sont
les bénéfices du côté de l'entreprise je
suppose que ça permet de détecter des
talents et de pouvoir les garder
exactement alors les bénéfices de
l'entreprise du côté d'entreprise sont
nombreux également donc tout d'abord
former un jeûne assez méthodes à ces
techniques à son produit etc et le
rendre immédiatement opérationnel si on
lui propose un CDI par la suite ça c'est
la première chose
la rémunération attractive
des charges qui sont soit très faibles
soit pas du tout de charge ça c'est
important et puis aussi participer à la
formation des jeunes et pour pouvoir
passer le relais et détecter comme vous
le disiez des talents alors je le
rappelle vous êtes la directrice d'un
campus qui réunit trois écoles on a
l'école Pigier qui est spécialisée dans
le management on a l'école maille
digital School qui est plus réalisé dans
le digital et le numérique et win sport
School qui est spécialisé dans le
management du sport ce sont des secteurs
qui recrutent en ce moment ce sont des
secteurs qui recrutent notre j'allais
dire notre ADN c'est de former des
jeunes pour les intégrer sur le marché
du travail donc les formations que nous
proposons sont forcément des formations
qui qui préparent à l'entrée sur le
marché du travail donc on trouve du
travail sur tout ce que nous proposons
comme vous l'avez dit chez Pigier nous
avons différents alors pas que du
management nous avons également de la
comptabilité du commercial de
l'immobilier
d'assistanat de direction etc
nos jeunes que ce soit chez my digital
school chez Pigier ou chez
windsportschool trouve à 85 % un emploi
tout de suite immédiatement à la sortie
de leurs études on
parle d'app
rentissage
c'est quoi la différence alors c'est
quoi la différence les deux types de
contrats font partie de ce qu'on appelle
l'alternance le contrat des pratissages
c'est une modalité principalement pour
les jeunes faciles pour les jeunes
jusqu'à 30 ans juste en dessous de 30
ans et le contrat d'apprentissage le
contrat de professionnalisation pardon
c'est pour les jeunes au-delà de 30 ans
ceci dit que ce soit en apprentissage ou
en contrat de professionnalisation c'est
le principe de l'alternance et dans sur
notre campus nous avons la fois des
jeunes qui sont en contrat
d'apprentissage donc moins de 30 ans
mais nous avons également des jeunes qui
reviennent faire leurs études qui ont
plus de 30 ans qui sont en contrat de
professionnalisation ou en réinsertion
professionnelle
depuis le covid des jeunes en
reconversion qui cherchent à faire de
l'alternance on a c'est vrai qu'on a à
la fois des jeunes qui sortent
immédiatement de terminale mais nous
avons également des jeunes qui ont fait
une année alors soit une année de césure
soit
[Musique]
la charge de travail ça nous aide
beaucoup
chef d'entreprise et je prends aussi des
alternants dans mon entreprise et pour
moi c'est essentiel justement pour
pouvoir les former pour pouvoir leur
mettre le pied à l'étrier et on voit
aussi ceux qui sont faits pour pour le
métier pour lequel il se destinent et
puis ceux qui finalement un moment
disent bah non ben je préfère arrêter je
veux passer à autre chose donc c'est
aussi un
[Musique]
comment un levier pour eux de tester
aussi un métier un marché sur lequel il
se prédestinait au départ quand
est-ce que c'est la communication mais
la communication ça englobe beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses et il y a la
communication c'est très large au sens
du terme donc il y a beaucoup de donc là
il voit vraiment ce que c'est c'est
vraiment très bien et vous avez des
conseils Nathalie Baluteau pour pour
ceux qui n'ont pas encore trouvé leur
alternance au mois de juin
venir nous voir venir chez Pigier chez
my digital school ou chez win déjà pour
notre expertise dans le domaine de la
formation et de l'apprentissage et puis
aussi parce que nous avons su créer tout
un réseau et nous travaillons
actuellement avec plus de 500
entreprises partenaires qui nous
prennent des jeunes tous les ans donc on
peut dire aujourd'hui qu'on est en
mesure de proposer une entreprise aux
jeunes qui se présenteront donc chez
dans nos écoles donc j'ai pigé ma
digital School et win merci beaucoup
Nathalie pas du tout d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en plateau je le
rappelle vous êtes la directrice de
trois écoles à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux Pigier maille
digital School et win sport school un
peu de culture maintenant le comédien
Arnaud Mayer sera sur les planches de la
Royal Factory à Versailles demain soir à
20h30 il jouera
joue devient un one-man show tiré d'une
histoire vraie il s'agit d'un comédien
qui a parcouru 2500 km en 100 jours
[Musique]
et si l'aventure que j'ai vécu il y a 20
ans où on a décidé de partir faire le
tour de France à pied pendant trois mois
2500 km pour aller ouvrir un théâtre
chaque soir dans un village où il y
avait jamais eu théâtre où les gens
découvert un spectacle pour la première
fois de leur vie je raconte cette
aventure avec plus de 22 personnages que
j'interprète seul sur scène et donc
voilà c'est un combat théâtre
complètement immersif puisque les gens
font vraiment l'aventure les spectateurs
sont vraiment ambiancés parce que toute
la bande son a été créée avec des bruits
de campagne de plein de choses et la
mise en scène de Clotilde d'agneau aide
à cela aussi pour vraiment que le
spectateur soit vraiment en symbiose
avec avec le comédien sur scène
[Musique]
ça fait 20 ans que ça me trottait dans
la tête et à chaque fois je racontais
des anecdotes qui ne sont arrivés
pendant tout ce périple les gens me
disent pas possible c'est incroyable ce
que vous avez vécu et je me suis dit bon
je vais peut-être en faire un seul en
scène et chose faite maintenant depuis
un an que je le joue
[Musique]
pour rire pour avoir plein d'émotions
c'est un spectacle qui traverse toutes
les émotions inimaginables comme je le
disais j'interprète 22 personnes sur
scène qui se donnent la réplique en
permanence le son les lumières sont
assez dingues et c'est vrai que les gens
à la fin souvent disent on a
l'impression d'avoir fait les 2500 km
avec vous et on s'est régalés on a vécu
une vraie aventure ça a vraiment un road
movie mais à pied donc si vous voulez
faire du sport tout en restant assis
venez donc
à 20h30 jeudi soir le 22 à la Royal
Factory
[Musique]
une idée de sortie à présent pour ce
week-end dans les Yvelines si vous êtes
amateur de rock ou non la seconde
édition du ouest Music Festival et de
retour à molette c'est ce dimanche de
11h à 21h pour en parler avec nous
Stéphane gornes le maire de la commune
alors pour le ouest musique festival
l'ambiance américaine et complètement au
rendez-vous alors exactement il reste
plus qu'à chausser les santiags et
mettre son chapeau de cow-boy et puis
venir passer un après-midi enfin toute
une journée d'ailleurs ça démarre à 11h
ça finit à 21h30
il y aura cinq concerts qui vont se
dérouler s'enchaîner toute la journée
avec des animations également
de la restauration qui est prévue sur
place
des expositions de voitures alors et de
moto alors orienté Harley Davidson pour
les motos orienté voiture américaine
côté voiture
cette partie sur sur la mairie qui est
tout ce côté là américain pour pour ce
festival à molette
c'était une histoire de rencontre j'ai
rencontré alors ça part un peu loin mais
vous allez voir un peu le rapport après
j'ai rencontré en fait Brigitte et
Pierre qui sont tous les deux
enfin président et vice-présidente de
l'association
d'éducation canine de molette et le jour
où je les reçois ils avaient tous les
deux un t-shirt Harley Davidson et
j'avais dans l'idée de créer un festival
en fait à molette et je voulais pas
faire un festival autour enfin un peu
classique j'allais dire comme justement
la fête de la musique je voulais faire
quelque chose d'un petit peu particulier
et puis on en discutant avec eux ils
nous ont ils me disent bah écoute nous
on peut organiser une rencontre avec
justement un regroupement d'Harley
Davidson
et puis de fil en aiguille on s'est dit
bah tiens Harley Davidson l'Ouest
américain et bah ce serait peut-être
l'occasion effectivement de faire un
festival autour de du rock et des
États-Unis voilà on vous l'avez dit à
l'instant tout au long de la journée il
va y avoir cinq groupes de musique qui
vont se succéder je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait on en parle juste
après
[Musique]
alors c'est une très grosse
programmation rock Stéphane bernes
qui vont qui vont se donc s'enchaîner
sur sur toute la journée les fuzzles en
fait c'est le premier groupe à 11h alors
c'est vrai que un début de festival
c'est toujours un peu compliqué parce
que il y a pas beaucoup de monde en fait
au départ donc j'espère que ce groupe va
attirer du monde justement il passe
quand même souvent sur sur les scènes
aussi bien de de
des Yvelines que d'Île-de-France ou même
ailleurs donc c'est plutôt du blues rock
pour pour ce groupe ensuite on a vu les
red cabbage les Red cabège c'est plutôt
de la country et en fait pendant cette
leur présentation enfin leur
représentation il va y avoir aussi des
cours de danse exactement de country
ensuite les harvest Blues Band étaient
déjà là l'an dernier ils ont mis le feu
au festival et donc on espère que ça va
être le cas encore cette année donc
c'est plutôt de la et du blues ensuite
les Dream On donc c'est du rock et du
blues aussi et on termine avec les
freaky Billy qui est du rock des années
50 donc avec des reprises comme Little
Richard ou Elvis alors autre dimension
de ce festival les motos et les
véhicules un peu de collection
c'est pourquoi c'est c'était important
de faire un regroupement de véhicules de
collection
effectivement et puis on a voulu
vraiment essayer de reproduire un petit
peu ce qu'on peut retrouver aux
États-Unis quand il y a des festivals
donc exposition de moto les groupes
viennent alors finalement j'ai une moto
je peux venir il y a pas de problème je
veux dire c'est pas sûr réservation il a
pas fallu appeler la mairie pour pouvoir
venir exposer sa moto ce sont souvent
des collectionneurs ce sont souvent des
gens qui font partie de de d'association
de de
de de passionnés de moto ou de voitures
et qui vont venir donc exposer leur
véhicule toute la journée
de Chevreuse et tout ça ils sont ils
sont ils sont énormément et il y a
beaucoup de plus en plus même à Paris
une grande une grande manifestation sur
les voitures les anciennes voitures et
tout ça c'est vrai que c'est je trouve
que ça ça revient et même au niveau
national tout ça revient ça revient à la
mode et il y en a qui qui c'est des
vrais collectionneurs et ils
chouchoutent leur leur bécane et leur
voiture mais c'est tout un et ça revient
je trouve que c'est c'est top et
l'associer je trouve avec
un festival ah ouais top bravo
effectivement donc vraiment on a envie
d'être dans l'ambiance américaine encore
une fois donc effectivement du rodéo
alors pas sur un taureau pas sur un vrai
taureau ce sera un terreau mécanique
mécanique
mais bon c'est déjà c'est déjà pas mal
il faut réussir à tenir je crois que le
record c'est quel c'est même pas 10
secondes je crois
et puis après des activités aussi pour
les enfants donc des jeux gonflables un
manège qui a tourné enfin voilà donc
l'idée c'est vraiment vous arrivez à 11h
vous pouvez manger sur place vous passez
la journée vous vous amusez avec les
enfants il y a des food truck également
qui sont prévus avec différentes
spécialités
et puis des spécialités aussi de
sucreries pour l'après-midi un stand de
bonbons qui fait froid plus de 20 mètres
de long enfin voilà c'est il y a
vraiment de quoi faire merci beaucoup
Stéphane vernest d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau pour parler du
ouest musique festival pour rappel ce
sera ce dimanche donc 25 juin de 11h à
21h dans la commune de molette allez
allez on continue de parler de musique
on va retrouver tout de suite notre
journaliste Mickael el midoro qui est
toujours sur place à Plaisir Michael
quelle est l'ambiance
à l'ambiance est très bonne ici à
plaisir les Mondays pêcheurs sont en
train d'interpréter hôtel California
juste derrière moi il y a environ 300 à
400 personnes autour de moi pour
assister à cette fête de la musique ici
à plaisir à mes côtés il y a Gérard qui
ne vient pas de plaisir mais des clés
sous bois mais qui a quand même voulu
fêter cette fête de la musique ici à
plaisir tout à fait oui absolument parce
que bon d'abord c'est en dehors donc là
c'est un petit peu c'était enfermé là
bon là c'est en parc c'est joli les clés
plaisirs on est quand même très cousins
on est à côté donc on est pas très loin
donc c'est vrai que c'était sympa puis
bon qu'il y a des orchestres il y a
peut-être des pistes qui vont sortir
là-dedans je sais pas c'est une grande
première pour vous à Plaisir oui
habituellement c'est vrai que je suis
plutôt clair c'est vrai merci je crois
que c'est la première année que je
du coup comment vous trouvez cette
soirée moi je trouve très bien
franchement ça sympa
bon il y a un peu de monde il y a
l'animation
c'est pas mauvais voilà c'est non c'est
bien franchement je trouve ça bien alors
au niveau du style il y a du rock pop
rock il y aura du punk peut-être un peu
plus tard des DJ c'est quoi votre style
à vous non j'ai pas vu style particulier
moi j'ai toute la musique comme ça voilà
tout ce qui vient j'écoute il y a pas de
j'ai pas quelque chose particulier
effectivement qui m'interpelle et vous
allez rester jusqu'à quelle heure je
sais pas
[Musique]
c'est jusqu'à 23h30 minuit environ juste
pour terminer petite musique peut-être
California ouais pourquoi pas
merci beaucoup Gérard je vous laisse
profiter de cet événement ici à plaisir
comme je vous l'ai dit entre 300 et 400
personnes ici à plaisir ils pourriez
avoir peut-être un peu plus de monde au
fur et à mesure de la soirée on aurait
tant entre 500 et 600 personnes merci
beaucoup Mickaël Elmi de rose je vous
souhaite également une bonne fête de la
musique profitez bien on se dirige
maintenant vers Guyancourt Grégory
pareil même question quelle est
l'ambiance à la batterie de Guyancourt
alors là pour le moment pour être
honnête petite pause ça va reprendre la
d'ici 5 minutes avec une ambiance pop
rock sur le parking studio de cette
batterie de lui en cours je vous
rappelle que il y a différents endroits
différents concerts qui sont proposés un
peu partout sur ce site de Guyancourt
différents concerts aussi dans la ville
de Guyancourt ambiance pop rock qui va
démarrer justement les deux artistes qui
m'ont rejoint font partie d'un groupe
pop rock c'est back and for World qui
est programmé à partir de 20h et ce sera
dans la salle de concert de la batterie
alors je suis entouré de Mathieu à Caro
qui est à clavieriste et de Thomas
Laurent qui est le batteur de ce groupe
Mathieu première question c'est quoi
back and for Ward pour ceux qui ne vous
connaissent pas alors c'est un super un
bon groupe de potes surtout ça c'est
très important et ça fait à peu près 10
ans qu'on joue tous ensemble qu'on
répète au studio ici à la batterie donc
on est un peu à la maison et on fait du
coup on a répertoire de reprise on fait
polyproproc mais des choses pas
forcément très très connues des blagues
Pumas des choses comme ça voilà croque
pour pour le style mais la fête de la
musique c'est important pour vous d'être
présent ce soir c'est un rendez-vous à
ne pas manquer chaque année bah oui
c'est c'est un peu l'objectif de chaque
année de faire la fête de la musique on
répète toute l'année à fond pour
proposer un concert exceptionnel
et donc je disais bah ce concert
exceptionnel il va il va démarrer voilà
vous la voulez bien vous avez bien fait
le teasing à 20h dans la salle de
concert venez nombreux qu'est-ce qui est
proposé ce soir
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a au programme
Thomas on a du Black too masse on a un
petit hommage quand même a Tina Turner
qui nous a quitté il y a pas longtemps
donc ça c'est la petite surprise donc
voilà on est plus une les
téléspectateurs tv70 le savent désormais
voilà allez tous dévoilé on a une petite
gastar qui va aussi arriver pendant
notre concert et puis quoi d'autre
Thomas des idées quelque chose à jouer
bah on a on a dû chercher Go aussi on a
du Starlight
plein de la pop et on peut donner on
peut donner rendez-vous à noter
spectateurs à 20h mais dès à présent
puisque les concerts ont démarré la
saveur prendre derrière nous vous voyez
les dernières répétitions avant que ça
reprenne ici à la batterie de Guyancourt
et donc les concerts à la batterie dans
la ville de Guyancourt vont se
poursuivre jusqu'aux alentours de minuit
je pense qu'on va on va vous laisser et
nous on va les profiter un petit peu de
cette ambiance musicale merci beaucoup
Grégory cannelés bonne fête de la
musique à vous aussi du coup du côté de
la batterie à Guyancourt allez c'est
l'heure à présent d'ouvrir une page
cinéma comme chaque mercredi on commence
avec le coup de coeur cinéma d'un
professionnel du 7e art cette semaine
c'est le réalisateur Gauthier Bara qui
nous parle du film l'innocent une
comédie récente qui date de l'année
dernière regardez
[Musique]
je vais vous parler du film l'innocent
de Louis Garet écrit par lui-même et
Naila Giguet avec
rushdenberg et Noémie Merlin c'est
l'histoire d'un homme à Ben interprété
par une qui apprend que sa mère
tombe amoureuse d'un homme en prison et
pour le Garrel Un homme en prison ne
peut pas sortir de ses habitudes
d'escroquerie et de magouille pour ça il
va s'épauler de sa meilleure amie
Clémence interprété par Noémie Merland
qui
vont s'épauler tous les deux pour aider
donc la mère de Adèle sauf qu'il va
faire la rencontre Abel de Michel
son nouveau beau-père
et de nouvelles perspectives vont
s'ouvrir à lui je suis ta mère je m'en
fous tu es complètement folle
[Musique]
nous propose un film de mélange de
différents genres nous avons une partie
film d'action nous avons film de comédie
romantique de dramex ustensile lougarel
sort de ses habitudes il nous propose
une histoire belle et émouvante qui
vient de remporter d'ailleurs de César
celui du meilleur scénario original et
celui de la meilleure actrice dans un
second rôle car oui on peut le dire
Noémie merlan casse l'écran par son jeu
d'actrice on peut dire aussi que Bugarel
s'impose en tant que grand réalisateur
par ce film en sortant de ses habitudes
avec un film intemporel au réalisme très
humain
[Musique]
un alien qui fait des pompes un alien
avec un haut de forme il y a quoi
là-haut le sens de la vie vous êtes qui
en a un vous êtes marié non
tu es en train de dire que notre mère
est morte trois semaines disons qu'elle
est au paradis qui n'existe pas pour moi
bien sûr mais vous êtes épices ou pas
bien dans ma solitude j'ai appris à
offrir une fois totale et
inconditionnelle à tous les gens que
j'aime alors je ne sais pas si tu en
fais partie mais ça inclus et ma fille
et vos quatre enfants parfois je pense
que je me sentirai plus chez moi en
dehors de l'atmosphère terrestre
[Musique]
comme d'habitude on se retrouve plongé
dans une fantaisie délirante comme c'est
si bien le faire ouest Anderson cette
mi-chemin entre le théâtre filmé et la
comédie de science-fiction et en plus le
film s'offre en casting 5 étoiles Tom
Hanks Adrian Brody Margot Robbie ou
encore scarlett Johansson pour ne citer
que vous nous proposez un autre
rendez-vous Céline avec un nouveau film
Pixar c'est elementaire oui des tranches
créatures cohabitent à element City ce
sont des êtres de feu dos de terre et
d'air mais attention la il est clair les
éléments ne se mélangent pas chacun à
son quartier c'est dans cette ville et
selon ce précepte que vont se rencontrer
flammes et flaques le problème et on
s'en doute flamme fait partie du clan
des flamboyants et flaque des aquatiques
elle a une vie toute tracée mais son
destin va changer avec cette rencontre
c'est une sorte d'histoire à la Roméo et
Juliette regarder donc tu n'es jamais
sorti de firetard désolé on est pas
compatible
mon père te ferait bouillir à feu vif
mais de quel droit les gens peuvent te
dire ce que tu es censé faire ou pas
on se demande à quoi servent ces
grillages
j'ai l'impression que tu as changé
un aquatique
ouais c'est l'appartement de ma mère et
il
y en a déjà quelque part
Marco Polo
un film qui prône des valeurs de
tolérance de vivre ensemble et
d'acceptation de soi c'est Adèle
Exarchopoulos qui prête sa voix à
l'héroïne et Vincent Lacoste pour flaque
votre sélection Céline avec une comédie
portée par Jennifer Lawrence on le
rappelle pour ceux qui ne la connaissent
pas c'est l'interprète de Katniss dans
Hunger Games mais cette fois-ci
l'actrice incarne un tout autre rôle et
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire son
personnage c'est Maddie une femme un peu
bimbo qui n'a pas froid aux yeux menacé
de perdre sa maison elle va accepter une
offre d'emploi assez étonnante celle
d'emmener un ado de 19 ans dans une
série de rendez-vous afin de le
décoincer en vue de son entrée à la fac
le tout en échange d'une voiture c'est
un film qui allie humour trash et scène
touchante il est réalisé par un ancien
scénariste de la série The Office bien
merci beaucoup Céline Charles pour
toutes ces idées de sortie moi ça me
donne quelques idées peut-être dans les
prochaines semaines direction
Dampierre-en-Yvelines à présent samedi
dernier plus de 200 pilotes ont roulé
avec des enfants dans la vallée de
Chevreuse le temps d'un après-midi lors
du rallye du cœur l'objectif avancer
dans la recherche contre les cancers
pédiatriques c'est le reportage de
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude et Régine
ralech
[Musique]
du soleil de la bonne humeur et de
belles voitures des ingrédients qui font
bon ménage ce samedi 17 juin plus de 200
pilotes de voiture de sport et de
collection se sont donnés rendez-vous à
l'occasion d'un rallye caritatif le but
faire profiter les enfants d'un tour en
voiture et collecter des dons en soutien
à l'association imagine formario
[Musique]
pour moi le radis du coeur c'est une
journée pour que les enfants sans cancer
et avec des cancers en profitent pour
s'amuser et oublier leur malchance suite
au décès de sa fille Margaux des suites
d'un cancer à l'âge de 14 ans Patricia
blanc fond de l'association en 2011 pour
venir en aide aux enfants malades depuis
imagine form margot est actif partout en
France et cofinance des programmes de
recherche pour lutter contre les cancers
pédiatriques
a donné 17 millions pour la recherche
contrôle cancer des enfants nous avons
mis en œuvre plusieurs programmes de
recherche qu'on a co-financé une
quarantaine de programmes de recherche
et nous aidons aussi une 400 familles
maintenant dans toute la France redonner
le sourire aux enfants c'est aussi ce à
quoi s’est engagé Alexandre Pacaud comme
les autres pilotes ce passionné de
voiture à collecter des fonds pour
l'association et emmène une bénéficiaire
de l'association qu'il paraît depuis
plusieurs années à bord de sa Porsche
pour une virée dans la vallée de
Chevreuse on va rouler sur environ 50 60
km pendant une bonne heure dans des
petits villages dans des petits trous de
campagne dans la forêt pour faire faire
un joli petit tour aux enfants dans nos
voitures ce 17 juin imagine form Margot
a collecté près de 310 000 euros de dons
un record pour l'association
c'est parti
[Musique]
et on termine cette émission avec un peu
de sport deux jeunes du club de rugby de
Montesson ont participé ce samedi à
l'orange Rugby Challenge à Marcoussis
puis ils ont pu assister à la finale Top
14 au Stade de France car Schuller et
Gabin quant à la bonsoir alors première
question comment est-ce que vous avez
vécu cette journée je suppose que vous
avez eu des étoiles plein les yeux tout
au long de la journée
Gabin tout ressenti sur cette journée
c'était vraiment très bien parce que on
a pu découvrir Marcoussis les terrains
ils s'entraînent les pros et on voyait
que c'était des très belles
installations alors quel était le
programme de cette journée Philippe
voilà le programme c'était vous êtes
arrivé je crois le vendredi soir à
l'hôtel non c'est ça le vendredi soir à
l'hôtel le samedi matin lisons comment
je dis on fait commencer les ateliers
ils ont commencé le matin
et ça c'était toute la journée jusque
16h30 quelque chose comme ça avant la
remise des prix et ensuite on est
direction le stade de France en Stade de
France à 19h30 ils ont fait le tour sur
la sur le bord de la pelouse du Stade de
France qu'ils ont fait tous les jeunes
les les 400 jeunes qui étaient là les
200 jeunes qui étaient là en finale
devant les 80 000 spectateurs
enfin on voit ce que voyez les joueurs
tout au long de la soirée Karl c'était
magique pour toi aussi
et après la suite
regardé la finale la finale du Top 14 et
une très belle finale en plus et ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que c'est quand
même comme je disais tout à l'heure 1100
clubs et vous êtes quand même dans les
40 il y avait 49 clubs en fait en finale
dont 29 masculins et 20 filles et donc
déjà d'arriver à passer les phases
départementales la phase régionale et en
plus finir sur là-bas dans vraiment dans
le temple du rugby ils ont eu en plus le
l'honneur aussi de de comme le nouveau
président de la Fédération Française de
Rugby qui a pris une photo avec vous
aussi qui a voulu prendre une photo avec
vous donc Florian grill et donc c'était
vraiment magique puis ils ont plus
confronté aux autres aussi sur ces des
ateliers et en plus il y a depuis la
deuxième année la deuxième année
consécutive il y a une atelier sur le
numérique aussi sur les bons usages du
numérique ils ont pu faire plus un
arbitrage sur l'arbitrage aussi donc
c'est assez je pense que
[Musique]
c'est Bayonne qui a gagné chez les donc
c'est quand même une terre de rugby donc
c'est Bayonne qui a gagné chez les
filles c'est un club breton c'est
Concarneau je dirais il y avait trois
clubs au niveau Île-de-France qui
participait il y avait le Racing en plus
avec le Racing se sont qualifié pour
l'Île-de-France et de Racing c'est comme
une référence que montée sur le club
monté sur le château puisse être en
finale donc je trouve que c'est une
belle récompense une belle journée tout
était bien tout était bien préparé ils
ont mangé là-bas ils ont ils ont pu
découvrir les installations là-bas et
ils ont vu des anciens joueurs voilà
c'est c'est
sur le stade un peu un petit peu ça fait
quelque chose et donc vous avez pu
échangé tout à l'heure vous le disiez
avec des anciens joueurs professionnels
pareil qu'est-ce qui vous ont dit
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont pu vous donner
comme conseil des conseils pour après
c'était les mêmes que les coachs mais
c'était des conseils
de compte 2 et il nous disait de se
placer plus vers extérieur pour plaquer
après etc et alors vous avez des des
joueurs préférés ce que vous prenez
comme modèle bah oui par exemple j'ai
viré mes Vakatawa et aussi Martin
Caillaud
c'est difficile de faire le choix et là
avec l'approche de la Coupe du monde de
rugby qui va se dérouler en France dans
quel état d'esprit vous êtes vous êtes
pressé vous allez peut-être pouvoir
assister à certains matchs non je sais
pas bah oui j'espère que qu'on assiste
qu'on assistera à plusieurs matchs mais
oui je suis très excité
une grande chance d'avoir la Coupe du
monde en France donc très impatient de
voir les matchs aussi que il y a des
anciens joueurs qu'on fait qui vont qui
ont fait la finale comme qui sont
qualifiés aussi qui sont en équipe de
France qui ont fait l'orange comme eux
l'orange la finale de national de
l'Orangerie je peux noter il y a Brice
Dulin de un joueur de de La Rochelle qui
est qui a fait la finale le samedi et
qui est qualifié ok en sélection il y a
bâtisseurin Morgane para Gael fikou
François Trinh-Duc ou encore Raphaël la
caffillasse c'est quand même des des
joueurs qui qui jouent encore ou qui
viennent juste d'arrêter qu'on fait
comme l'Orangerie donc je me dis que des
questions de mieux grandjables donc
voilà et ça donnait espoir que dans au
club vous allez pouvoir
plus tard c'est un objectif pour vous de
devenir joueur professionnel
moi oui mais je pense ne pas y arriver
mais oui ce serait très bien alors je
profite de parler un petit peu de la
Coupe du monde de rugby puisque le
sélectionneur Fabien Galtier a dévoilé
la liste des 42 blessés pour la Coupe du
monde de rugby je vous laisse regarder
sur internet pour regarder les prénoms
qui ont été sortis bien merci beaucoup
Philippe vos lac car le chaleur et Gabin
cantala d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci et d'être venu sur notre plateau
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 et une belle fête
de la musique prenez soin de vous
[Musique]